[Music]
uh
let's check out how you the people
they're still p you know there's still
people hanging out on youtube in that
dirty place i don't know it's [ __ ]
weird right radio legends you mean
mickey that have been doing radio since
he was 18.
don amos is dead
um
i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry i did that oh
remember that [ __ ] of course
i'm
yeah
uh
an hour
yeah we're not doing the whole thing
obviously he's shaney it's like she was
trying to help bro trump is even though
i live in trump tower he does i hate him
i didn't even bother to move out of
trump tower before i started talking
[ __ ] about the guy
and now the association keeps trying to
kick me out
you moved to trump tower when you were
at your heights because it was cool
because trump was cool what happened it
was one of the newer buildings and it
happened
so
opster the opie man opie and anthony of
obiang i just realized it yeah maybe he
just likes the taco balls too much
best of it
[ __ ] that's always going to be funny
to me
[Music]
there's a reason i picked this one why
does he do that every time is he
autistic well let me tell you something
the top comment in this
is absolutely describe the opi
top comment by dfn
i think it's hard for opie to change his
opinion on a lot of the situations he's
been in because his whole identity is a
fabrication that goes back decades he
doesn't uh know what he really is
anymore what the reality is but the
reality is any uh anymore so he just uh
commits to a convenient version of the
truth that benefits him in some way he
can't start questioning things or his
entire persona might collapse poor guy
and that's hurts more than any name
yep
all right it looks like we are live good
morning everybody welcome to my little
live stream from the ocean
and with that i say
of our tiny waters
you know i made the mistake again by the
way because i wanted to get i always
hate the tiny waters and i want to get
full-sized waters but i didn't look at
the ounces correctly oh someone's
thirsty hey don't drink it all at once
you get cramps snow you're gonna get a
cramp no that's too much that's too much
water merch no stop no first stop
you okay
somebody did that for a wee and died
oh no it's more water it's merch stop
he's killing himself on the show he's
killing him he's waterboarding himself
on the show
like my tiny water
it's like a cia black site
[Laughter]
you want any [ __ ] coffee with that
cream by the way but just drink sugar
milk at that point jesus christ man
actually coffee
i actually like more cream than what he
does in my coffee i like my [ __ ] to look
like a pair of khakis
coffee
seriously i didn't i didn't have time to
make a fresh pot so no one cares healthy
literally nobody cares this is microwave
coffee right here you're drinking
microwave coffee opie i live in a
two-bedroom [ __ ] apartment that's
basically in section eight housing
and i make it in a french press and it's
gourmet i would never drink microwave
coffee and i'm white trash drink coffee
that's not made in a french press it's i
have a french person out too so i
actually understand the the french press
life it's pretty awesome
it's [ __ ] animal
or
if you don't like someone you should
think
donated 69 on rumble which is very nice
of you also
nice
nice
thank you
welcome to rumble
nice here's a nice rant for you
you know what
thank you so insala
um in salah
[ __ ] salad salad are you are you
ordering a [ __ ] salad how do you say
i'm going to try it are you ordering a
salad in a [ __ ] pizza place right now
hear me out hit me up
no insula hear me out here is that hold
on is that the salad that comes with the
tomatoes and onions you throw away from
the pizza place you disrespectful
[ __ ] look i don't know man you
know all i'm saying like i'm gonna siraj
hear me out here all i'm saying is you
put an indian and a [ __ ] in the same
room i can't tell the difference listen
i just want to apologize um to all of my
muslim brothers out there our first day
here verified and uh the unacceptable
comments by russ
will not be tolerated and i can promise
you that he will be beheaded look here's
the thing
a lot of people [ __ ] talk [ __ ] about
muslims but hear me out here at least
they're not they're right about like 90
of
kids
they're right about 100 by the way
they're right about 100 how to treat
women
[Laughter]
i agree wholeheartedly
i think every woman should have her
twitter account taken away and they
should be wrapped in a burka tight like
a burrito and that should be their lives
hey
salami bacon brother
salami bacon all right okay this is just
is it racist no i just think it's
offensive to again my culture and my
people your culture you're joining the
boys really yeah i'm joining the boys
what party what party man what part of
iraq are you from dublin well because
then i can be racist i can be misogynist
i can mistreat women but you already do
that i can be violent to people yeah but
now i'll stop getting arrested for it
and i can just go excuse me i'm muslim
okay
good good
good good
siraj goes to be honest royce looks far
more pakistani than me
i'm cuban sir
yeah but you still look like you should
at least be given a little extra look at
the airport i am never be too careful i
am a guy that a [ __ ] cia recruiter
saw me they go
what's the guy do you want to learn
farsi can you learn farsi they were
trying to try to teach me fartsy
we're the guys we're all different
stereotypes right you know like the guys
at the tsa probably stand there and go
terror terror terror drugs drugs drugs
terror drugs and then when me and royce
come through they look at him it's
terror and they look at me like drugs
i'm all hungover i have sunglasses on
i'm like bro i swear there's nothing
virtue walks through rapists wait what
what
except he says it out loud he says it
out loud rapist
wait what
[ __ ] what
sorry we got off on a tangent the
[ __ ] picture how i'm going to
rape a [ __ ] draw a picture please don't
go please don't go back
okay no actually i want i wanted to go
hold on i actually i know how to find
his stuff depending on where what the
people are saying okay here we go then
because
they're just trying to start problems
what's up siegel
back to me yesterday because i wasn't
part of some did erock ask you anything
for steve c's tribute he put together so
this is actually pretty cool and i want
to give a shout out to erock
uh
recently yeah yesterday he put out a
three like a three hour tribute to iraq
where he kind of put a you know little
you know best of you know stuff that he
did on the show and it was actually
really cool i saw some of it was really
well done
uh and
sir
what's up donald
i don't think people understand you
that's a big deck thank you yeah
thank you very much that's funny
dick laugh i appreciate it
did erock ask you to do anything for the
steve c tribute he put together no i i
guess uh people were attacking me
yesterday because i wasn't part of some
steve c thing uh i a
did not know about it
uh
which means b no one contacted me about
it and c
i have no desire to do anything with any
of those people so
eero
stood by your [ __ ] side when
everybody and everybody he was in the
[ __ ] bunker under berlin with you
because he thought that you were
sincerely
[ __ ] weren't a piece of [ __ ] and now
the reason that you don't want anything
to do with them here's the reality opie
let me change the narrative for you let
me tell you let me tell you the truth
let him control your narrative right
that means no no no topo supercedas are
no [ __ ] super kicks no vaccines no
vaccines
no no wellness policy either for sure
i'll tell you that yeah watch one
interview with ec3 you know that whoo
that guy boy is oh yeah
so
um [ __ ]
coke and steroids are always a good
combo ask eddie guerrero every wrestler
died in the 90s right
um
so
the truth of the matter is it's not that
you don't want to do stuff with these
people see what he's trying to do is
frame it
these people
don't want to do stuff
with you
see that's the difference that is the
difference ob is such a disingenuous
piece of [ __ ]
uh there you go but uh
i think of steve c uh quite often sure
um
yeah i mean i would too if i made
somebody kill themselves that's all i
think about
and i'm sorry man but i am of the
opinion that your actions
started a spiral in that guy and made
him kill himself i'll say this
it off it didn't help i'll say that it
wasn't a helpful thing part of it i
think it was the breaking point dude
that whole show that shows his whole
identity
for [ __ ] how long 20 years more
so like yeah that's pretty [ __ ] up
like that would i would expect like i
would tell you let me can i put it this
way
if uh if you and i
had like a real producer no offense
virgi or frozen uh
no but if we had like
undertaken i don't even know why you
guys feature net guest digital yeah if
we had a gas digital setup and we were
around for 20 years and we had the same
goddamn producers in those booths
working with us and you know what i mean
paying them and stuff and they got gigs
outside of the place because they were
connected to us and their whole thing
right and then we just went yeah you
know what fire that person after 20
years we don't need them just save a
couple bucks around here and then like a
year maybe a less they kill themselves i
would personally go
holy [ __ ] i killed that person yeah
would you not go like first we killed
that person of course like you know what
i mean
maybe not that far but i would
definitely feel like i had a [ __ ]
party piece
yeah
and uh you know if they put something
together uh for steve was listening to
you befez was listening to make fez cry
yesterday remember when he did that
see you know god bless them good for
them that's a nice thing to do but i had
no idea about it
i hate these people but it's a nice
thing to do god bless them
and if anyone tells you differently they
could go f themselves because that's the
god's honesty [ __ ] you could say [ __ ]
opie [ __ ] is fine go f yourself man yeah
truth
i only started hearing about it when
people started attacking me why weren't
you part of this i i i didn't even
respond to that but no merch brought
this up last time we talked about you
opie how come you're not part of any of
the old crew because all the old crew
kind of splintered off but they're still
like you know cool with each other i
know they intermingle
even if they're not all together they
still intermediate jimmy goes on
anthony's show he goes on you know their
stuff it's everybody pops around chip
chipperson there's no beef there's no
open hostility is the point right except
with you of course you're the one that
doesn't go to any of the parties
they're just trying to start problems
he's like howard stern without the money
or the talent just all the bad parts and
then and then you wanted to [ __ ] with
carl
um man by the way you were just like the
angel of death
everybody around you just [ __ ] dies i
know vic henley
cuban carl who i didn't mind i thought
carl was nice um
uh
christy stefano sherrod you you got this
little crew together and then that was
what started the beginning of the end
for you is when you went no i can't just
be a part of this new loose knit group
of creators that all used to be the same
thing i have to be the don and i have to
have my i'm gonna go make velvet
revolver yes well no even velvet
revolver the guys got like
guys from other prominent bands this was
more like [ __ ] i'm hiring session
musicians and you'll do what the [ __ ] i
say this is billy corgan hiring like
five obscure people and going nobody
gives a [ __ ] who you are the rolling
stones black bassist
he'll sing see thank you jay warren
always uh always uh i don't know
i was adjusting myself in bed and inside
the blanket and and this damn dog he
could sniff uh some some goodness why
would you lie and say they were both
talking about your okay the audio
tagging your last livestream comments uh
comments was howard talking about
manchester's father and dicey he was
uncomfortable with the conversation why
would you lie and say they were both
talking about your father it's not true
just knock it off but
no
you can listen to the audio now he's
doing is that true because i never
really heard the idea without that
yeah um i do remember that actually
uh
dice pushed back a little opie's problem
was dice didn't push back enough
basically you know it's not true
it's not
true facebook user
god we live in a world where you could
just you could just make up [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] look at that hottie huh yeah
pulling the hotties you could live in a
world where you could just make up [ __ ]
like you made up that rich voss showed
up with a diaper full of poop and i know
for 100 fact that it was staged since
the morning and it wasn't really poop
but you're right you could live in a
world where you can make stuff up huh
opie
shut the [ __ ] up buddy i know a lot
about your little made up world that you
created around you so you probably
[ __ ] calm down
literally says opie in the clip
why would you do this like just by
thought right
but
if you're on vacation right
you get a nice little beach house a
couple [ __ ] days and maybe even a
whole summer just chilling out yeah why
would you spend your mornings drinking
coffee and talking to an entire chap
that hates you i just feel like that's a
shitty way to start off your vacation
your house is going to make 63
i don't know man
it's a good point i mean how what's he
gonna do
what's he gonna do
i i i just i i just don't have time for
that anymore you know we it's so obvious
we live in a world where
where fake news is king
what does that even mean
yeah i always knew alex jones was a
piece of [ __ ] even though i had him on
my show several times after the sandy
hook thing yeah trump's a piece of
garbage even though i live in a place
that has his [ __ ] name written in
gold at the top of it
i i live in a monument to a man i talk
[ __ ] about on a daily basis
it really is
that's my favorite part about the anyone
who hates trump
is what's whatever but i'm sure a lot of
rich elites that like hated trump
probably at least moved out of trump
tower out of like [ __ ] this guy and you
just you're gonna sit there and bash him
and still live in his [ __ ] building
which i'm sure even if you own it the
trump trump still makes money off of you
from being in that building i'm sure
there's fees you know what i mean so
yeah yeah keep giving them money it's uh
mental uh
instability required for good radio yeah
i'll tell you the god's honest truth man
you know my comfort zone was being with
insane people
and that's why when i was building a
massive radio show he built a master
radio show it was all him anthony didn't
do [ __ ] bro i i found the insane people
he found them not they weren't jimmy's
comic friends
they were his friends
if you want to know the truth that's
exactly what happened
like comfort all right looking over the
right clearly lying guy got it zone was
what was chaos you're looking over your
shoulders make sure someone's not
[ __ ] fact checking you live hobie not
anymore by the way
and maybe that's why some people find me
a little more boring these days because
i don't feel like living in that chaos
the wife finds you boring too
i bet
you the only conversation he's probably
had with his wife all day was when she
walked through
the beach house and said
you put the you put the towels in the
washer last night and you forgot to put
him in the dryer
and then just walks away and he's like
uh yeah he doesn't like to live in that
world every morning can we go over his
videos because he doesn't like living
that world he all he does is he makes
[ __ ] these terrible thumbnails by the
way
and it's all clips of like opium anthony
lets uh egos get in their way insta
uh
jimmy used to be funny but he's not
anywhere look at all the times just this
reason jim norton was part of the opiate
indonesia
so this is just like um
he's just tr he really needs money yeah
yeah
uh
is
it's the opium anthony show without opie
they do realize they're literally just
doing the opi anthony show without being
without anthony right
there's a ton of other stuff to check
out when i when i do these uh live
streams you can be listening to howard
the reason you see this like this is
because his his internet connection is
so bad he figured if he puts a filter on
it oh you're right yeah oh my god
because a lot of them are so pixelated
looks like he's in a [ __ ] aha video
if you still like that
you could be listening to the uh the
opium anthony show that is now being
done by jim and sam
they know that right
they do realize they're literally just
doing the opi anthony show without
opinion with that so you mean two guys
talk anytime soon guys i'm sorry
on that now go [ __ ] yourself opie suck
my dick so anytime two guys do a show
they're doing the opium anthony show two
guys have never done a show ron and ron
are copying open anthony ron and fez
we're copying opie and anthony
paul and young ron if you're from south
florida let's go down the [ __ ] list
everybody caught every morning radio zoo
show copies opie
shut the [ __ ] up opie shut the absolute
[ __ ] up i don't like by the way jim and
sam however i have listened to their
show and they're not doing opie and
anthony they're doing half a wrestling
show and half of a sex addict show and
then they squish them together it's not
opie and anthony yeah and then they just
take turns looking in their phones right
so uh come on
shut the [ __ ] up
anthony right they did they at least
know that are they at least admitting
that
i clicked on you look at the graphic he
keeps doing he's a boomer he's a [ __ ]
boomer dope it's like on one of their
social medias the other day i'm like
this is all stuff
oh sorry sorry and said why why are you
in one of their social medias because i
know they do really two people you're
talking about you blocked so now are you
going on burner accounts or going in
incognito because you do actually care
what they're saying opie and anthony's
show that is now being done by jim and
sam
they know that right
anthony right they they at least know
that are they at least admitting that
i clicked on uh one of their social
medias the other day i'm like this is
all stuff we did a million times they're
still talking to to to colin quinn and
and vos is still coming in on a regular
basis so they're literally doing the uh
so they're not gonna have friends
they're friends on
by the way colin quinn
and rich voss
were [ __ ] jim norton's friends before
they came on your show yeah literally
his friends like like
like
specifically floss yeah is jimmy's
friend from like their hack jersey days
yeah from like early 90s like nobody who
knew that like they were doing open mics
and [ __ ] in jersey together so yeah that
was like that's funny that's hilarious
he and
that's about as much opie as i could
stand and then colin yeah he only
started coming in because he liked
[ __ ] on jimmy yep and then that just
became a regular thing